l'holographie est avec nous merci mais
non merci
[Applaudissements]
tu sais quand m et tu sais que voilà on
est avec toi tu as moins compter sur toi
sur chaque dossier
ça c'est vraiment grande gentillesse
matin à mon chez astellas rocha qaîda et
commercy mesfar vraiment et lolo voulait
absolument venir ce soir parce qu'il
voulait vous parlez aux téléspectateurs
voulez vous raconter et que c'était là
nous raconte son histoire parce que
c'est une histoire complètement folle et
il faut faire quelque chose parce que il
faut plus que ça arrive et il faut d
aider c'était là le loup raconte nous
alors c'est là est mon ami depuis de
nombreuses années elle a participé à pas
mal d'émissions avec moi et voilà on est
on est assez proches et moi je sais pas
du tout qu'elle va pas bien et l'appel
lancé le coup puis on a un ami commun
qui me dit t'es au courant que cela va
pas bien je l'appelle tout de suite
et là je la trouve effondré pas bien les
enjeux failli me faire amputé des deux
jambes
oui waouh je tombe du lit je veux dire
explique moi et elle m'a expliqué son
parcours qui a été très très vite dans
dans l'infection quand tu va raconter
mieux alors parce qu'il ya vingt ans
j'ai fait des injections de silicone
dans l'intérieur des cuisses des fesses
et des amplis pas moi
voilà en fait quand j'avais 20 ans je
fais 7,7 ces logis en fait nous les
transgenres en fait ce qu'on cherche
c'est plutôt à voir là les formes pas
fait le corps parfait et puis parfois le
parfait devient très dangereux si le
tabac là je me suis fait un j'ai quitté
calmement injecté par des prothèses dans
l'est de l'épaule et de les sécher dans
le plastique en fait c'est vraiment des
injections dans le corps alors avec des
piqûres valadon que je suis content de
selecon 3 liée à l'époque on disait que
ce n'était pas du tout dangereux en fait
voilà c'était une clinique en fait à
cette clinique
comment dire qu'ils n'étaient pas dans
les normes
une clique ou mal comme je peux dire ça
à l'école clic on dit steve redessine
valeur est en fait le produit que la
médecine la médecin elle a dit qu'elle
avait mis dans ma jambe en fait c'est un
silicone médecine elle en fait il sait
pas du tout local en fait c'est un deal
silicone industriel c'est ce qu'on
nettoie les moteurs d'avion
en les moteurs des voitures voilà et
donc ça fait depuis cinq ans cinq ans
jusqu'ici à chaque année pendant l'été
gd grosse grosse inflammation à la jambe
ça gonfle terriblement je te silicone
s'est propagée dans votre cuisse va là
et les nouilles impôt vert lessive
silicone y atteint qu'ici le silicone
atteint les eaux faut savoir qu'elles
risquent donc l'amputation des deux des
deux jambes
c'est complètement ouf alors vous pouvez
pas travailler à cause des douleurs et
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de cas je vous
dis de chirurgie esthétique de dérive de
chirurgie esthétique c'est pour ça qu'on
voulait en parler ce soir avec laurent
baffie alors il ya des gens qui font
très bien leur travail mais mine de rien
il faut faire super gaffe
alors notre histoire elle et elle est
complètement folle parce qu'aujourd'hui
une idée complètement folle ce matin en
fait en fait voilà j'ai passé un
week-end 3 à l'hôpital l'hôpital
saint-louis j'ai passé trois jours de
fièvre très forte et j'ai failli avoir
une embolie boli embolie pulmonaire
en fait c'est un poney creusé en fait et
puis heureusement je remercie mon dieu
en fait parce qu'en fait il reste encore
un espace qui n'a pas encore atteint
l'os donc c'est le temps qui dit on m'a
donné en fait pour pouvoir m'occuper de
moi et pour enfin enlever ce produit qui
s'est complètement nocives pour la santé
et puis heureusement que je suis
accompagné à côté d'une association qui
s'appelle à 71 qui est en fait je ne
sais pas la seule en france et on a déjà
arrivé à plusieurs cas depuis que j'ai
mis mon cas en évidence pour tous il ya
pleins pleins d'autres personnes comme
moi qui ont adhéré
jimmy - m vous êtes médecin voulait dire
quelque chose
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on écoute votre
histoire c'est terry mais vous l'avez
bien dit c'est une clinique clandestine
ne doit pas faire peur non plus aux gens
la chirurgie esthétique mais finalement
ça peut très bien se faire assure france
il ya un peu un bout mais on a peu
préservé parce qu'un parti publicité 2
finalement on les médecins sont assez
rigoureux et puis on a quand même malgré
tout les réseaux sociaux et le danger
est là c'est qu'on voit de plus en plus
notamment sur instagram des femmes
proposées des injections à un tarif
imbattable et lorsque forcément au
propose une injection trois ou quatre
fois le prix en dessous de celle d'une
clinique il faut se poser les questions
1 de la compétence 2 du produit 3 du
suivi et des risques donc le risque
c'est surtout pour les chirurgies
clandestine
en fait en fait d'accord avec vous mais
en fait à tout type de produit injecté
dans le corps qui skie c'est pas naturel
c'est dangereux pour la santé
ça soit à la bouche ça c'est l'icône du
collagène sein du botox
en fait maintenant il ya un nouveau
produit qui à pied dans le marché et que
c'est très très très nocive pour la
santé c'est très dangereux
en fait peu importe le produit qui vous
mettez dans votre corps c'est dangereux
pour le pas trop jaloux tu voulais dire
quelque chose mon lolo jusqu'à il ya
quelques secondes pardon tu voulais dire
quelque chose mon loulou il ya déjà deux
secondes avant que jimmy prennent la
route parce que pourquoi ça va non je
pousse à savoir le nom du produit dont
tu parles de nouveaux produits peut-être
pour alerter les gens c'est ça ressemble
au scandale des prothèses mammaires des
gens qu'on a peur en disant il ya vous
inquiétez pas ça bougera pas ça peut pas
bouger
ça fait 20 ans mais ya pas de recul non
il
un lolo pourquoi tu as décidé toi
vraiment de t'investir c'est mon ami m a
pas lieu de deux jours elle a failli
mourir et elle me dit il faut il faut le
dire parce que je ne suis pas le seul
transsexuels dans ce sens et ça il ya
ben ça ne touche pas que les
transsexuels ça touche les femmes aussi
les injections ndibu faut le dire il
faut faire passer l'info donc tu
j'appelle moi j'appelle j'appelle mon
petit rim qui me dit viens immédiatement
donc voilà je l'association j'ai pas le
portillon viens de le dire la wii moi je
suis parade de sa de l'association
d'auteurs de paris gilles verdez que
vous avez pu vous retourner contre la
clio 4 ans est en fait à l'époque la
période ça j'avais 20 ans vous savez et
puis en fait je je savais en fait
en fait en réalité je ne savais pas que
c'était une clinique ne dessine
c'était un doctor qui est venu qu'est
venu en fait de l'argentine et qui a
installé un cabinet donc voilà donc qui
ont envahie ont mes amis mes copines
enfin mes copines en train de faire une
sortie de la toute belle et tout ça est
en fait voilà le mans entraîné j'ai
tombé dans le piège puis voilà ggg cédé
il ya 20 ans lci bon moi je vais je vais
y aller alors il ya eu des choses hyper
grave qui sont passés je vous dis dans
lé cadre d'opérations de chirurgie tic
je voulais montrer un extrait qui est
assez fort c'est celui de fabienne qui a
perdu sa fille partie faire une
opération de chirurgie esthétique en
tunisie alors je vous dis en tunisie il
ya une très très bonne clinique faut pas
généraliser c'est vrai que ligne de
reims et sont même peut-être les
meilleurs là bas ils font des trucs met
l'accent sur les mêmes ont été très bons
mais elle c'est vrai qu'elle a eu un
drame
regardez
fabienne et contre la chirurgie
esthétique c'est donc en secret que sa
fille s'est envolé pour la tunisie avec
une amie
sur la table d'opération marjorie meurt
d'une embolie pulmonaire elle était
pourtant en bonne santé
impossible de savoir ce qui a causé
cette complication le compte rendu
opératoire a été battue et fabienne a
porté plainte contre x pour homicide
involontaire
lebel photo des prix attrayants mais ça
ça vaut pas le coup de mourir pour de
faire ça non ça vaut pas le coup
voilà dos c'est vrai qu'il faut faire
très attention voilà sur la chirurgie
esthétique alors la plupart du temps ce
sont des bonnes clinique là on voit ce
qui est arrivé est hélas tu es en plus
il ya vingt ans la 20 ans après c'était
là elle vous l'a dit elle est en danger
elle risque de se taire amputé des deux
jambes
c'était là aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire qu'est ce qu'il est possible
de faire et qu'est ce que vous allez
faire je sais qu'ils ont entendu parler
d'une opération pour retirer le silicone
qui peut se faire soit en france voilà
soit en colombie voilà en fait en france
aléas des médecins et des médecins
extraordinaire vraiment en france à nous
avons presse les laisser les meilleurs
médecins médecin au monde mais en fait
pour mon cas post genre de situation en
france il descend pas encore au point
je sais pas c'est de locuteurs peut me
dire on passe même si vous connaissez je
sais pas en fait en france et sont pas
encore habilité pour ce genre
d'opération donc j'ai fait le tour du
monde
en fait de toutes les personnes que je
connais des personnes qui ont ils le
même cas que moi a partout dans le monde
dont qui en sont le nom qui dansait le
dr amir sca bogota et lima bogota en
fait l effet une nouvelle technique pour
en fait il a déjà eu des cas comme ça
voilà c'est jerry voilà le silicone
industriais mal à ça donc il a une
technique et leur technique parce que le
silicone loghmani morose en fait
scientifiquement valent pas long pour
les moros en fait elle devient très dur
donc en france les médecins ne veulent
pas opérer comme ça demeure de son père
d'opérer d'avoir des complications
accord est en fait à bogota en colombie
des assets docteur il a une technique
aux fêtes et le dissolue le silicone à
l'intérieur d'abord du jour 10 au balo
le baladi et le dessus la villa médicis
et pas cher
et puis et puis amour une fois que le
silicone et devient liquide et il aspire
et l'accord va pas entrer dans les dom
et voilà il
l'opération pourrait être rapide elle
pourrait l'être si 1000 salles a en fait
au fait à voilà j'ai de la chance aussi
parce qu'en fait mes patrons du banana
café où je travaille là bas aussi
et ils ont organisé une cagnotte en
ligne d'accord voilà combien la
caennaise aujourd'hui vous êtes à
combien elle à 9 900 euros
900 euros il vous faut entre 6000 et 10
mille euros c'est ça les sous pour pour
voilà pour pouvoir financer votre
opération est pour aller en colombie
pour faire cette opération
combien de temps vous avez c'est la
stella qu'est ce que vous disent les
médecins ben le médecin ils ne m'ont pas
réellement pas vraiment me dit mon
modique
voilà tu as tu as jusqu'à à faut aller
vite quoi voilà il fallait veiller à ce
que chaque jour voilà ça voilà c est un
moment on pourra plus faire l'opération
c'est ça parce que ça n'a plus rien
voilà il faut il faut agir vite va la
baisser c'est pour ça que lolo nous
appeler
je vous ai pas appelé pour qu'on parle
de la de la cagnotte de stèles c'est moi
pas du tout parce que cette année nous
appeler pour parler du truc ça s'est
réglé la cagnotte de stella se régler
d'accord ah bravo le loup l'histoire
vous a appelé pour parler de
sensibiliser les personnels général des
lions qui s'apprête à faire ça du tout
d'argent n'est pas venu ici pour vous
demander d'argent
j'ai exposé mon cas et a plein d'autres
personnes d'accord femmes transgenres
qui m'ont fait des photos qui m'ont voix
de témoignages mac il souffre
terriblement et qui peuvent pas mine de
rien je suis repéré parce que
l'opération cours à l'arrêt très cher
donc fait attention à la chirurgie
esthétique vraiment et lolo
encore une fois je vois que les tt voilà
bah t'es vraiment une bombe de mec non
mais c'est vrai voilà parce que tu
penses toujours c'est mon ami mais je ne
pense pas que la stella tu penses à tous
les autres oui mais parce que tu es là
est mon ami voilà oui mais les autres
aussi ce qui est bien sûr tu me dises
appui à la seule émission te reçoit des
personnes que personne ne reçoit
personne c'est vrai le lot mais voilà la
solution
politis pas remarqué mais ta voisine et
manque une jambe et à l'épaule comme ça